Hello, everyone.
My name is Eyal.
I'm managing the marketing
and the business development
activities in PlayScape.
And today, I'm going to
talk about strategies
for distributing
games on Google Play.
And I'm going to wrap things
up by providing a few tips
and tricks that we have
been using at PlayScape
and hopefully you
can use yourself.
But before I start,
I do want to say
that all the information
that I'm going to talk about,
all the data that you're
going to see here,
is based on our own experience.
So if you have
contradicting data,
if you have a different
point of view,
just come to me after the talk.
And you can tell me
how much I was right.
But seriously now, I think that
we do live in an environment,
work in an environment that
is changing really fast.
And I think that the
only way we can keep up
with all the major changes
is to talk about them.
And on a different note,
since everything around us
is changing so rapidly,
I think that we
tend to get caught in
the day to day tasks.
And it's hard to keep track
on the bigger picture.
So instead of talking about
marketing tactics and numbers
and figures, I want
to start by talking
about something a
little bit different.
I want to talk about soccer.
I mean, everybody's talking
about the World Cup.
Why can't we?
So I want you to
imagine yourself
standing in a soccer stadium.
And you're standing there.
And you're given a task.
And the task is to make everyone
listen to what you have to say.
What do you do?
So one way to go
and that's probably
the most obvious approach is
to start making some noise.
But the problem with the
most obvious approach
is that it is the
most obvious approach.
And some other people that are
also fighting for attention
might be a little
bit louder than you.
So games marketing is
just a bit like that.
And instead of the soccer
stadium, we have Google Play.
And in Google Play, there
are more than one million
applications.
I mean, think about
this amazing number
for just a second-- one
million applications.
If I start playing
those applications today
and I'm going to dedicate
five minutes to try and test
each one of those,
it's going to take me
decades to use them all.
If I plan to sleep, it can
take me up to 20 years.
So people don't
really get excited
about new game launches.
I mean, nobody's going to open
Google Play and say, hey, look,
a new game.
Games are invisible.
And that's why 99%
of them disappear.
So discovery is a big
challenge in the mobile space.
And I think that, as a result,
a lot of game developers
resort to using advertisements
as their main strategy
for distributing their game.
The way that every
advertising strategy goes
is follows-- you buy some ads.
You make some noise.
You use the ads to
create distribution.
You take the distribution
and you generate revenue.
You take the profit.
You invest it back to ads.
And the process goes
on and on and on.
And the thing is that this
strategy does not always
work for a few reasons.
First of all, going back
to the soccer analogy
where some people might have
been a little bit louder
than you, in the game space,
there are other first tier game
publishers like DNA and king.com
that have marketing budgets
that you probably do not have.
So if you want to be able
to compete with these guys,
you cannot do what they are
doing because they can do
a much better job than you will.
If you want to complete
examples for the games space,
you can look at two type
of games in Google Play--
first of all, games
that monetize using ads,
and other games that monetize
using IAP inner purchases
by selling virtual
items in their game.
Now, although those
two categories of games
fall within the
games category, they
are essentially very
two different products.
So a game that
monetizes using ads
is going to generate about $0.02
for every daily active user.
A game that monetizes
using IEPs--
I'm talking about games that are
doing an amazing job monetizing
the users-- can make about $0.12
per day per daily active user.
Now, this is six times more.
And although it's not 10
times more or 100 times more,
it is sometimes the difference
between making money and losing
money.
So if king.com can afford
themselves to buy users,
for instance, for $1.00
and still make a profit,
a game that monetizes using
ads is going to lose money
for every user they buy.
And if you think
about it, it also
goes back to the nature
of the way we think
and the way we act
when you see ads.
So the best example
I have is about me
buying gummy bears,
which I really like.
So when I want to
by gummy bears,
I'm going to the supermarket.
And there's a wide
variety of gummy bears.
So I don't want to see
ads about gummy bears
because I don't have
a gummy bears problem.
And I think this is the way
people look at ads generally.
To be honest, I think that
people don't care about ads.
But they also don't
care about your product.
I mean, they simply don't
care-- at least, some of them.
We are living in a
me, me, me world.
And I think this is
partly because people
think that they
have way less time
than they used to
and way more choices.
And in a world where people have
way too many choices and way
too little time, the
most obvious thing to do
is simply to ignore stuff.
So if you want to
market your game,
you don't want to use
mass marketing and talk
to all of these
guys, because they
have become really good
in ignoring your ads.
And I think that what we
have to do is to find a way,
instead of talking
to everybody we can,
to get our ideas to spread.
And it doesn't matter to me if
you're running a coffee shop,
if you're an artist, or if
you are distributing games.
I think this stuff
applies to everyone
regardless of what they do.
And the people who know how
to spread their ideas win.
Now, in order to
do that, I think
you have to have
two key components.
The first one is
having good content.
And I think that you have
to do your proper marketing
research in order to
find the right content.
And you also need to use the
right marketing tools in order
to get to the core
group of users
and create a snowball effect.
Now, this slide, I think,
represents the dynamics
between content and marketing.
So if people say that content
is king, marketing can be queen.
And some people who say that
she is wearing the pants.
However, to market
the product, to market
an idea or a game that
doesn't stand out,
that is not unique,
that is not remarkable
is always impossible.
And I think that everybody
that works in marketing
is going to tell
you the same thing.
The thing that's going to
decide what gets discussed, what
gets done with it, and
possibly what gets purchased
is whether your
game is remarkable.
And remarkable is
a really cool word
because we think it means neat.
But it also means worth
making a remark about.
And that's in the
essence of getting people
to talk about our games.
"Don't Tap the White Tile"
is a remarkable game.
For those of you
who don't know it,
it's a "Tap Tap Revolution"
game for mobile.
What you have to
do in the game, you
have to touch the black tiles.
You have to avoid
the white tiles.
And if you manage to do
it, the game plays music.
And the game is beautiful
and ugly at the same time.
And when came out
to the market, it
was the only one of its kind.
"Dumb Ways to Die" is
a safety announcement
by Metro Trains in
Melbourne, Australia.
It's a safety announcement.
And you've got more than
10 million downloads, only
in Google Play.
And you have to trust me
when I say they did not
invest $10 million in
promoting this app.
And I think what they did
is to game-ify the safety
idea of what they
wanted to portray.
And also, they present it in a
very graphical but very amusing
way, the way you can die.
"Flappy Bird" is
not a very good game
if you look at game practices.
I mean, people cannot play it.
And even those
people who can, they
want to smash their
device into little pieces
after a short while
of playing it.
But you all know the
result of the game.
"Ninja Chicken" is
one of the games
that we've published
in PlayScape.
It's about a chicken
who thinks it's a ninja
and lays eggs wherever it goes.
And what it came
out to the market,
people didn't
understand whether it's
a female chicken
or a male chicken
or why exactly it lays eggs.
But the game stood out
and they talked about it.
And for us, it was
an amazing success.
It reached the top of the
charts all over the world.
"Monster Smasher" is
another game by PlayScape.
And it had solid gameplay
and really nice graphics.
But I couldn't market it.
So how do we explain when things
don't go according to plan,
or even better, when others
manage to achieve things that
defy the fundamental
assumptions-- why
some games make it to the top
and other games, developed
by developers that are better
funded and more experienced,
do not.
Why some games downloaded
by millions and millions
of the players and other games
are buried in the land slide.
So to be honest, I don't
think that a lot of people
can really tell and can really
explain why some games succeed
and some games fail.
But I think that if you look
at the top of the charts,
there's something really
clear that is happening.
Every month, there
is a new game that
is leading the
top of the charts.
And it's never the best game.
It's never the best funded game.
It's never the game that has
the biggest marketing expense.
But those games are there
because they're unique.
They're fresh.
And they provide something
new to the target audience.
And I think that our
industry, in a lot of ways,
is led by trends.
And this year's
collection of games
is nothing like next years.
We ware working in
the fashion business.
No matter what game you
develop, no matter what genre it
is, it's the fashion business.
And this thing is
that people who
work in the fashion business,
they know how it's like.
But the rest of us, we have
to start thinking their way.
And we have to
realize that it's not
about presenting the users
with a full page ads.
But it's an entirely
different process
of getting people to
talk about our games.
Now, you could not be reassured
that people will do that.
But I think that
innovation is key.
You can innovate by
creating a new concept,
like the guys of "Don't
Tap the White Tile."
You can innovate by
using a slick design
or crazy creatives, like we
did with "Ninja Chicken."
Or you can use technology.
And I think that
the Dirtybit bit
is doing a really good job
with their game "Fun Run",
which is the first
real time multiplayer
[INAUDIBLE] game for mobile.
However, if you
think that you're
going to launch your game and
then people will magically
gravitate toward it, you're
heading to a surprise.
And I think that once you
have something that is worth
talking about, you
have to be able to find
the core group of people that
will care about your product.
And they will listen
because it's not about you.
It's about them.
And if you're lucky
enough and if you're
doing your job properly, they
will talk to their friends.
And they will talk
to their friends.
And your idea will spread.
It to spread to the
rest of the curve.
At the heart of finding
the right people,
there's targeted marketing.
Now, targeted marketing
was not even an option
up until a few years ago.
I mean, some brands did use
the geolocation of the device
in order to create
targeted campaigns.
But to be honest, I
think that this option
was rarely available.
And marketeers had no idea
what to do with it anyway.
What we're seeing today
is that ad networks
that manage to take the
geolocation of the device,
and they translate into
user profiles and segments.
So according to where
the device lives
and the type of people
that visit those places,
they can draw conclusions
and bucket them
into demographics, [INAUDIBLE],
and other user profile
segments.
And with social
media, social networks
today, we can even get a better
understanding of our users.
So the technology
is definitely there.
And we can use it in order
to get to the right people.
But now, we have to form
a strategy around it.
So I want to guide you through
what we're doing in PlayScape
and how we launch our games.
So I think when we first
launched our games to Google
Play, it was very important
for us to understand how now we
can [INAUDIBLE] margin
between the money we spend
and the money we earn.
And in order to do that,
we had to learn Google Play
and to understand how it works.
So there were a few
things that we used,
a few methods that
we used in order
to lower the user
acquisition costs.
So first of all, we
used targeted marketing.
We talked about that.
We also used cross promotion.
And cross promotion
is a great way
of getting a few downloads
at a price of one.
So you acquire one user.
And then if you
have other games,
you can cross promote them to
the next game, the next game,
and generate a few
downloads out of it.
Using the charts is a
great way of getting people
to discover your app from
looking at Google Play.
You have to know exactly
how many users you
have to drive to your game in
order to get to a specific rank
and how many users
you have to continue
to drive in order to
sustain your rank.
But if you know how
much you have to do
and how many you get
in return, that's
a great way of generating
organic traffic.
Word of mouth is not
something you can rely on.
But we definitely have to
start thinking that way.
If you have a game that
is worth talking about,
it's important to understand
how we communicate
it using your marketing assets
to your potential players.
Search is another
great tool that
can allow you to
make your game pop up
when people are looking
for specific keywords.
So for instance,
"Ninja Chicken" pops up
when people are just searching
for ninja games, which
drives a lot of
organic traffic for us.
Now, we can't start
off by doing search
because you have to have a
critical mass of downloads even
to pop up in key words
that are not very popular.
But once you do get
that critical mass,
that's a great
way of scaling up.
And of course, there's press.
The main thing I want
to say about press
is that if you're using it
as a way for getting users
to play your game, you should
not use it as a way for people
to play your game.
But it is a great way
for getting recognition
and to talk to the
key decision makers.
So if you're looking
to form partnerships,
this is a tool you should
definitely consider.
So what you see
here is a graph that
shows the launch of
one of our games.
And it shows you
the exact number
of downloads we got every
day from day one to day 30.
And the color represents
the traffic source.
So the blue colors stands
for the organic traffic
that we generated.
And as you can see, in the
first day of the launch,
we drove a lot of traffic.
But then, very fast,
we started getting
a lot of organic
traffic, which means
word of mouth,
charts, or search.
What might be interesting
for you to see here
is that although we drove a lot
of traffic in the beginning,
after that, we used
specific and very targeted
promotional spikes only whenever
the game needed the support
in order to continue to grow.
And that can save
you a lot of money
if you are able
to work that way.
Now, it's not an exact science.
But it is almost
an exact science.
And if you want to be able
to understand the data
and to analyze it, you
have to stay data drive.
We invested a lot of
resources in creating
both the infrastructure and also
recruiting the right personnel
in the company in order to
be able to track the data
and to analyze it.
And one cannot do
without the other.
And it allows you not only
to operate efficiently
in Google Play,
but it can also let
you do something else
that is very important,
which is to test everything.
Now, I know that a lot of people
are talking about A/B testing
and how important it is.
It's not just a slogan.
It really is true.
I mean, I wish I
had some more time,
so I can so you the
different ads that we
are using for the games and how
surprising the result can be.
But we don't have the time.
So you have to trust me.
But testing is really important.
And I think that if you
want to work efficiently,
you have to make
your assumption,
create the respective
segments, and then test, test,
test everything against
each other and other.
And another guideline
that follows us
and that we follow in
everything that we do
is that we try to remember
that marketing does not
equal advertising.
I mean, advertising
is really important.
It's an important part
of every marketing plan.
But I think that
sometimes, we just tend
to forget that there's
so much more we can do.
And we tend to look at the
users as numbers and figures.
And I think that the industry
is doing an amazing job
in dehumanizing our users,
calling them whales.
It's not only unethical.
I think it's also
counterproductive and not true.
And I think that if you
want to be truly successful,
we have to go back to basics.
And we have to
realize that it's not
about presenting our
users with a full page ads
and grabbing them by the throat.
But it's an entirely
different process
of getting our idea to spread.
And people who know how
to spread their ideas win.
Thank you for listening.
And I hope you have a good
and fruitful conference.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]